salut nous sommes le 23 février 1964
place Vendôme à Paris alors je dis pas
que vous y êtes et qu'on est en 64 c'est
juste la tempealité le lieu de mon
histoire monsieur Germain le
propriétaire d'une bijouterie de la
place Vendôme c'est reconnaître assez
facilement il a comme un petit talent de
mentaliste pour savoir qui est très
fortuné qui ne l'est pas quand quelqu'un
franchit le seuil de sa boutique et ce
jour-là la bijouterie est vide quand une
énorme Rolls Royce se garde devant la
bijouterie mais il observe et voit le
chauffeur sortir de la voiture ouvrir la
portière de son client ouvrir la porte
de la bijouterie et aux vêtements à
l'attitude à tout ça il sait que c'est
pas un gros client c'est un très très
gros client vous avez compris on est
dans un nouveau alls raid une histoire
un petit peu à la pierre Bellemare c'est
comme Astred mais il y a pas d'horreur
en fait il y a mais il y a des
rebondissements rassurez-vous si vous
voulez voir aussi les anciens épisodes
il y en a une petite dizaine ils sont
tous en lien dans la description il y a
une playlist le client qui descend de la
Rolls est un homme un bel homme
d'ailleurs d'une quarantaine d'années
avec des vêtements cachemire plutôt une
allure sportive il est très bronzé ce
qui détonne avec la période de à Paris à
ce moment-là et il y a aucun doute sur
le fait que ses vêtements viennent de
très grands couturiers monsieur Germain
a pas dû faire un accueil digne de son
standing il remarque également qu'il a
un plâtre au bras droit ce qui lui fait
penser comme on est en février et par
rapport aux bronzage que ce très gros
client revient d'espoir divers et le
bras gauche porte une mallette en cuir
ça c'est peut-être pas un détail pour
vous qui est important mais c'est
important parce que en général c'est le
chauffeur dans ces cas-là qui porte les
mallettes les bagages etc c'est assez
étonnant que celui qui porte sa propre
mallette ça veut dire qu'elle contient
des choses très personnelles ou
précieuses le très gros client rentre se
fait accueillir par monsieur Germain
monsieur Germain lui demande ce qui
demande il répond à peine et il regarde
un petit peu tout ce qui est en
bijouterie l'herbe blasé derrière les
vitrines et c'est pas étonnant et c'est
à peu près l'attitude que monsieur
Germain connaît de cette très gros
clients des gens un petit peu blasés qui
ont pu tellement de désirs parce qu'ils
peuvent tout s'offrir et acheter un
bijou même hors de prix c'est pas une
grande aventure pour au bout d'un moment
le client dit à monsieur Germain je sais
pas je sais pas vraiment la recherche en
fait je cherche un truc un peu simple
c'est notre anniversaire de mariage avec
ma femme c'est tout faut juste que je
marque le coup et le bijoutier a
l'habitude en fait de ces demandes de
très gros clients ces demandes de je
cherche un truc d'assez simple en fait
c'est pas vraiment ce qui cherche il a
l'habitude de ses attitudes de tout ça
il connaît ce langage donc il part à
l'arrière de la bijouterie et se dit je
vais chercher quelque chose de très
précieux et d'un peu unique une fois à
l'arrière et celle le bijoutier se dit
mais j'ai une pièce j'ai une pièce
maîtresse presque une pièce qui a fait
une petite réputation pour lui du fait
qu'il l'est c'est la pièce la plus
coûteuse qu'il possède et il dit je
tente le coup quand même de lui
présenter parce que lui c'est sûr a les
moyens de l'acheter cette pièce est une
broche qui représente une marguerite et
elle est composée uniquement de feuilles
d'or et de rubis c'est un véritable
petit chef-d'oeuvre ce qui vaut
également ce prix évidemment monsieur
Germain va pas lui présenter que ça donc
il lui ramène d'autres pièces des
bracelets des boucles d'oreilles des
bagues etc et le client va examiner tout
ça pendant une heure sans être très
intéressé par l'ensemble et monsieur
Germain va inventer les mérites de de
chaque objet qui va lui présenter en
particulier les mérites de la broche en
forme de marguerite fait de rugby et de
feuilles d'or alors en termes de
Procédure voici comment ça se passe
monsieur Germain a fait sa sélection il
la met sur un plateau il la met à
l'intérieur d'une vitrine cette vitrine
elle est fermée à clé et comme les pieds
sont très très cher il y a une procédure
qui est simple à suivre de sécurité
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'il présente
une pièce et qui va en présenter le
mérite il ouvre le tiroir il sort la
pièce du plateau il referme le tiroir à
clé on regarde cette nouvelle pièce et
une fois que c'est fait on ouvre on la
pose dedans on sort la prochaine et on
referme la clé donc il y a toujours une
seule des pièces qui est sortie à la
fois et comme ça on est sûr de rien
perdre à ce prix là ça fait un peu cher
la perte elle a tout un tout arrangé le
client demande quand même à revoir une
dernière fois la petite broche la petite
marguerite de rugby et de feuilles d'or
donc l'intuition de monsieur Germain
était plutôt bonne ça a l'air de prendre
un petit peu le gros client la réexamine
monsieur Germain a pour lui qui sait que
ce genre de très gros client n'a pas
envie du tout de passer la journée à
chercher le cadeau qui veut faire à sa
femme pour un anniversaire de mariage
donc s'il trouve quelque chose de
satisfaisant il peut lui vendre et il a
visé juste le gros pied en dit vous avez
raison c'est une très belle pièce je la
prends donc maintenant il faut passer à
l'étape du prix le bijou qui est lui
rappelle avant d'annoncer le prix qu'un
petit peu sale quand même que c'est une
œuvre d'art que c'est une pièce unique
que c'est quelque chose qu'on ne reverra
jamais ailleurs donc il y a une
spécificité il lui annonce le prix de
200000 francs et c'est 200.000 francs de
1964 donc ça fait plus de 300000 euros
aujourd'hui pour une petite broche qui
représente une petite marguerite autant
vous dire qu'annoncer ça à n'importe
quel client ça le ferait réfléchir lui
il a extrêmement les moyens ça lui fait
pas bouger une oreille qui dit c'est bon
je la prends mais il a un petit souci il
voudrait payer en liquide et il a avec
lui dans sa valise en cuir selon lui
seulement 100.000 francs de liquide
est-ce que ça vous étonne peut-être moi
ça m'a étonné mais ça a pas du tout
étonné monsieur Germain le bijoutier qui
est plutôt habitué à ces choses là c'est
pas la première fois de sa vie que
monsieur Germain voit des clients des
sommes un peu indécentes par rapport à
nous en liquide sur eux donc il est pas
surpris que quelqu'un ait que 100000
francs sur lui pas de 200.000 francs
c'est comme si vous croisez quelqu'un
qui qui disait ah c'est 300000 euros un
an j'ai que 150 000 en cache là sur moi
mais monsieur Germain a peur de voir sa
bellevente sans voler parce que il a pas
réservé il veut pas lui réserver non
plus parce que il a l'habitude que c'est
du gros clients là après ne reviennent
pas c'est c'est il fonctionne pas comme
nous quoi s'il va aller ailleurs trouver
autre chose avec ces cent mille francs
l'acheter et puis voilà fin de
l'histoire donc il essaye un peu de lui
faire peur en disant ben voilà je peux
pas vous la réserver comment on peut
faire à ce qu'il y aurait pas une
solution quand même parce que vous avez
pas d'autre choix de paiement est-ce que
vous pouvez pas obtenir facilement les
100 000 francs qui vous restent et comme
ça force d'argumenter il arrive un peu à
faire peur aux clients qui a commencé à
s'attacher à sa broche au fait de
l'avoir trouvé et vous savez il y a un
principe psychologique simple qui est
derrière c'est que comme il a décidé de
l'acheter maintenant il a vu s'il a pu
il a l'impression de de perdre quelque
chose le biais cognitif de la version à
la perte donc pour lui c'est déjà devenu
sa broche il s'est déjà vu l'offrir à sa
dame donc il a peur il veut pas que la
broche a lui passe sous le nez et
qu'elle soit vendue à quelqu'un d'autre
ou quoi alors le très gros client a une
bonne idée il demande un papier à en
tête de la bijouterie oblige aussi qu'un
stylo et dit je vais écrire un petit mot
à ma femme et elle va faire en sorte là
que j'ai descendu francs voilà je vais
écrire un mot et mon chauffeur va lui
apporter ça il revient avec les 5000
francs et comme ça l'affaire est réglé
monsieur Germain lui confie papier
crayon et le gros client commence à
écrire de la main gauche puisque son
bras droit est dans le plâtre mais ça se
voit qu'il est pas gaucher et c'est
c'est illisible donc il demande
plusieurs feuilles à monsieur Germain il
se reprend à plusieurs fois il arrive
pas à écrire son mot et toujours dans
l'attitude un peu stéréotypée de
certaines personnes très fortunées bah
monsieur Germain voit son très gros
client commencer vraiment à s'agacer et
il se dit là à tout moment il va me dire
non mais en fait c'est bon Marguerite ça
me saoule je la prends pas faites-moi
voir ce que vous avez pour 100000 francs
et monsieur Germain a peur du coup de
encore rater la vente donc il se permet
une proposition et d'ici vous voulez et
si vous me le permettez je peux écrire
le mot à votre place le très gros client
admet que c'est une très bonne idée il
commence à lui dicter le texte le texte
et le suivant ma chérie pourrais-tu
remettre au chauffeur une enveloppe
contenant 100000 francs
issus de notre coffre ne lui pose pas de
question c'est une surprise que je te
destine et qui je crois te plaire à fort
il lui dit de signer par son nom Georges
et explique au bijoutier qui aura pas de
souci parce que même si c'est pas son
écriture puisque de toute manière c'est
son chauffeur habituel qu'elle connaît
qui va apporter la lettre qui va lui
expliquer et elle est très bien au
courant qu'il a le bras dans le plâtre
le chauffeur parle c'est la femme du
très gros client et puis pendant ce
temps-là les les deux hommes discutent
pour occuper un petit peu le temps et
d'ailleurs le bijoutier fait une blague
en disant j'ai même pas fait un faux en
signant George parce que le hasard est
marrant on s'appelle tous les deux
Georges ils ont le même prénom il parle
tout et de rien de la Bourse de Megève
parce que le bijoutier monsieur Germain
avait vu juste son client était allé
skills à Megève et c'est là-bas qui
s'était cassé le bras bref ils ont de
quoi papoter pendant que le chauffeur
fait le nécessaire et revienne et ça
dure pas longtemps 30 minutes d'après le
chauffeur est de retour il confie au
très gros client une enveloppe qui est
très très épaisse et la transaction peut
se poursuivre il y a dans l'enveloppe
1000 billets de 100 francs donc oui
c'est vrai que ça fait une certaine
épaisseur quand même c'est pas une
petite enveloppe comme quand on voit les
vœux pour pour le nouvel an et donc le
client les sortes mais des liasses ça
dont j'ai parlé à ça sur le comptoir
elles sont comptées il ouvre sa petite
mallette en cuir il sort les autres cent
mille francs la somme est là elle est
complète on est clairement sur une
montagne de billets je sais pas si vous
imaginez quand même mais il y a 2000
billets de 100 francs si vous voulez au
moins vous lisez 2000 billets de 100
euros autant vous dire que la bijouterie
est fermée à clé le temps de compter les
sous parce que ça aussi ça fait partie
des procédures de protection on va pas
faire ça n'importe comment monsieur
Germain est ravi il un petit range tout
ça en même temps discrètement il vérifie
que ce sont bien des billets normaux qui
sortent bien de la Banque de France il y
a pas de problème et à 100% sûr il y a
pas de problème avec les billets il
raccompagne enfin le client jusqu'à la
Rolls Royce avec le chauffeur le client
qui par évidemment avec sa petite broche
en rugby et la faire est faite c'est ce
qu'on appelle une bonne journée le soir
monsieur Germain rentre chez lui dans un
immeuble très costume dans le 16e
arrondissement de Paris il est très
content de cette journée particulière
pour lui une journée à grosse vente
c'est pas tous les jours non plus et en
montant à l'appartement il se dit qu'il
va inviter sa femme au restaurant parce
que pour un peu célébrer ça et puis en
plus sa femme elle lui reproche beaucoup
de passer énormément de temps au travail
il se dit là on pourra célébrer là je
vais je vais lui réserver du temps que
pour elle mais quand il ouvre sa porte
sa femme semble extrêmement intriguée
déjà lui dit qu'elle ignorait qu'il
avait un chauffeur à sa disposition et
que elle était inquiète quand même de
savoir pourquoi il lui avait fait vider
le coffre
et cette école à surprise parce que on
parlait pas d'une et là c'est comme vous
monsieur Germain vient de comprendre
grosso modo ce qui s'est passé il est
pris d'un gros malaise il enlève sa
cravate il a une bouffée de chaleur il
demande un verre d'eau à sa femme il
s'assied parce que ses jambes le portent
plus il comprend qu'il a eu à faire un
escroc un arnaqueur et surtout un coup
de maître dont il est la victime le
chauffeur était nécessairement accompli
c'est le fameux très gros clients
connaissait nécessairement l'adresse de
monsieur Germain et le prénom pour faire
le même prénom et puis voilà si vous
dites comment il savait que monsieur
Germain il aurait 100 mille francs en
espèces chez lui à cette époque c'était
très courant surtout pour les gens
fortunés d'avoir des coffres chez eux et
d'avoir énormément d'espèces d'avoir un
coffre chez soi c'est encore très
courant pour les gens très fortunés et
monsieur Germain était
notoire très fortunée également comme la
plupart des propriétaires de bijouterie
de la place Vendôme et donc le chauffeur
il s'est présenté chez la femme de
monsieur Germain avec un mot écrit par
monsieur Germain à part sa main je veux
dire à la reconnu l'écriture
signée par un bon prénom avec le
chauffeur qui lui explique que c'est son
mari le bijoutier qui a envoyé ça et on
est en 1964 il y a pas un téléphone
portable pour appeler et puis vérifier
vite fait et à n'a aucune raison de se
méfier et là ça devient assez agi parce
que monsieur Germain commence à
engueuler sa femme et à lui dire mais
comment tu as pu donner 100000 francs un
inconnu elle elle-même si elle a dit bah
c'était ton écriture c'était ta
signature enfin je sais pas moi et donc
il lui prend la tête pour ça et tout ni
mais pour une surprise 100.000 francs
pour une surprise toi tu te dis je te
fais des surprises à 100000 fois
pourquoi et elle elle tombe ensemble
elle s'est dit bah justement comme on se
fâche beaucoup en ce moment sur le fait
que tu es jamais là etc je pensais que
tu voulais me faire une énorme surprise
pour notre anniversaire de mariage qui a
lieu demain et alors ça je sais pas si
les Scrolls savaient ou pas mais le
hasard voulait que monsieur Germain
avait aussi son anniversaire de mariage
le lendemain et donc tout devenait
crédible le bijoutier monsieur Germain a
porté plainte on n'a jamais retrouvé
l'homme qui était le grotescro mais
j'étais assez marrante dans cette
escroquerie c'est que c'est une
opération blanche à l'équilibre c'est à
dire que lui il avait donné 100 quand
même plus les 100.000 francs qui la taxé
directement au bijoutier pour acheter la
broche à 200 000 mais il a pas gagné
d'argent dessus je vous explique
pourquoi parce qu'en général les bijoux
voulaient ils se revendent moitié moins
cher que leur prix dans le circuit légal
et si à ça on rajoute quelques faux
frais il a bien fallu louer cette Rolls
Royce il a peut-être fallu payer au
moins le chauffeur payer quelques
recherches je sais pas c'est quasiment
certain qu'il a qu'il a pas gagné
d'argent en revenant à la broche et
limite qu'il en est perdu un petit peu
alors pourquoi il a fait ça mais
peut-être pour l'offrir à son épouse à
lui pour de vrai il s'est dit bah voilà
ça n'écoutera pas bien cher comme ça
cette histoire enfin pas bien cher ça
lui aura quand même coûté 100000 francs
c'est pas mal ou alors il l'a fait pour
reprendre la beauté du geste juste parce
que enfin la beauté du geste illégal
quand même on va le préciser mais parce
que monter cette arnaque la tenter et en
plus elle fonctionne c'était pas dit que
ça fonctionne son histoire et puis au
pire si le chauffeur revenait sans
l'argent bah il disait bon ben je
l'achète pas ma femme était pas là et
puis il partait avec il a il avait quand
même pas trop de risques à tenter le
coup et ça a marché peut-être il a fait
ça pour
comme pour la broche pour créer son
petit chef-d'oeuvre personnel mais
illégal j'ai quand même beaucoup
d'empathie sur le bijoutier parce que
c'est pas comme dans l'histoire des
tableaux volés avec le directeur de la
galerie d'art lui
il méritait pas mais on est moins
empathique si vous voyez pas de quelle
histoire je parle c'est un ancien old
state que j'avais fait que dans la
description à très bientôt Ciao